Hey guys welcome back, thanks for joining us today on the king of random not too long ago!
We had a video showing you how to build a flamethrower out of a used fire?
Extinguisher and in that video I gave a short demonstration of how to breathe fire today
I'm going to explain how to minimize the risk if you're going to try breathing fire yourself
I'm going to be demonstrating two different methods of breathing fire one is with cornstarch
and one is using lamp oil the other supplies that I have with you are a couple of dish towels one full size towel a
Gallon of water and a stick that I'm going to make into a torch
Corn starch as a powder is not nearly as flammable as the lamp oil
It's easier to use because there's not as much preparation and there's not as much danger to swallowing it or breathing it in although you
Definitely want to avoid doing both of those things now for both the lamp oil and the corn starch
We're going to need some fire that we can hold and control so the first step is to build a torch
Let's take one of our rags and cut it into thinner strips. I'm gonna cut this into about thirds
With this strip we can tie it around our stick and our torches almost done
We'll soak the cotton in lamp oil and light that and that will work as a torch that will resist going out from the wind
Once our torch is burning
We're going to want a way to safely put it out
So I'm going to soak this towel in water and have that near me so when I'm done breathing fire
I can just drop the torch into it and cover it with the wet towel
Water evenly distributed throughout the whole town
We go at this point once our torch is assembled. We're ready to try using the cornstarch. Here's what I'm gonna
Do I'll light the torch on fire then we'll take a scoop of cornstarch and put it in my mouth
I'll stand up and I'll blow the cornstarch out of my mouth through the flames
And I'm explaining that I'll now because once I have a mouthful of cornstarch. I won't be able to talk much here we go
Oh
Now my whole mouth is full slightly damp cornstarch from that's disgusting
Gross let's do again
It's really unpleasant, I don't like cornstarch in my mouth
But it lights on fire well enough
We have some coffee creamer leftover from try it our fire extinguisher flamethrower, so I'm gonna see if this works with coffee creamer
Horse all right, I think it wasn't quite as good of a flame as with the cornstarch
But I don't hate having it in my mouth as much because it doesn't clump up nearly as badly
And it's got like a lot of sugar taste to it so that's a plus there you go
We had pretty good results there with the cornstarch now
We're gonna move on to the lamp oil lamp oil which is also called liquid paraffin is a clear oil that burns fairly easily
Lamp oil is a petroleum product. That's often used for fire breathing because unlike other more refined petroleum products
It doesn't easily get absorbed into the tissues in your mouth
There's a few main things that we need to make sure we're being safe about the first is to not swallow or breathe in oil
That can be extremely harmful or fatal the others
We don't want to have this stuff dripping down our face while we're reading this stuff out because we really don't want to catch our
Face on fire it's no fun so before we go on to moving the oil we're going to do a little bit of practice
Using water when we're breathing fire with oil
we really only need a very small amount at a time only a
Tablespoon or two what we're gonna do with the water is practice to make sure we can hold it in our mouths and then spit
It out without having any urge to swallow it or breathe it in what I'm gonna
Do is put a little bit of water in my mouth and then hold my mouth shut and just practice holding it in there
Still being able to breathe in and out I'm going to pluck off the back of my throat so they're not accidentally swallowing or breathing
Where I don't want
The next thing we want to practice is how to spit the water out you don't want to spit it in a nice little stream
You actually wanted to sort of spray everywhere that'll help it atomize and really catch on fire better like this
You'll also may notice that when you spit it like that it starts dribbling down your face this brings us to our next safety precaution
We'll have a damp rag
and
We'll just either hold it or leave it right on our shoulder so that anytime we get any oil on our face
We can quickly wipe it off now that we've practiced by using water, and we have our wet rag
We're ready to start using oil and the torch alright
I'm going to put a little bit of oil in my mouth like I said before it's only one or two tablespoons
You don't need a huge mouthful
And if you do you'll probably end up triggering your gag reflex or almost swallowing neither of those things are good
So you use less oil at first if you think you want to build up to a little bit more at a time?
You can do that. I'll put some in my mouth
I'll set the oil container down away from where I'm going to be breathing fire
I'll make sure I'm holding my wet rag in one hand and the torch in the other and then I'll spin it out through the
flames
I'll hold the flames starting about a foot and a half away from my face
And as I breathe I'll pull a torch farther away. I don't want to get the fire too close to my body here goes
There you go, let's get a little bit more oil and try again
You can probably see that before I breathe and in between each breath on to the fire
I'm wiping my mouth off with the rag
This is just to keep any oil off in my face because I don't want to risk my face like a fire
Seen it happen that had a wet cloth, so he like was able to put it out quickly, but he lit his face on fire
The lamp oil has very little smell and almost no taste whatsoever
But it does still leave a very oily feeling on the inside of your mouth
It's not super pleasant, but I actually strongly prefer it to the cornstarch
They're having two different methods of breathing fire cornstarch and lamp oil I am NOT a big fan of the cornstarch method
I know it's a lot safer, but I hate the feeling of having cornstarch in my mouth
It just instantly gums up and sticks to your teeth and mouth and gums and lips and everything
It's just awful using the oil is its own sensation
It does make the inside of your mouth feel very oily of course
It doesn't have any flavor
But it's still a little bit odd to have it in there the oil of course is much more dangerous to use you need to
Make sure you don't leave it in you need to make sure you don't swallow it
Always practice with water to make sure you can easily hold the liquid in your mouth without accidentally breathing in or swallowing
I've also found that it really helps if you're holding the liquid in your mouth to keep your face pointed down so if you do
accidentally start to breathe or swallow it doesn't immediately go down the lung - if you're trying to fire breathing make sure you have the
Right safety equipment be sure you've got a wet towel and wet washcloth standing by
Put out your torch or anything that you might light on fire that you don't want to be on fire
Fire breathing is a pretty cool trick and be learned in just a few minutes time
I hope I don't need to say this but never try and use anything more flammable than lamp oil don't use lighter fluid
Definitely don't use gasoline because that's explosive when it lights because you could really really badly hurt yourself even with the lamp oil you
to be absolutely sure you take precautions
Not get it on yourself if you ever get any on your clothes
Stop change clothes immediately. You can get it on your face use your wet rag
Wipe it all off so your face can't catch on fire. It's your face. You don't want your face to be on fire
Thanks for joining us in this video today, and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
Like having a mouth full of what?
Yeah, now it's drag
Hey guys. I hope you're having a great day. You are awesome. You are appreciated
I know everyone over here on my team is really grateful for you. Thanks so much for choosing to watch and support our videos
We'll see in the next one